hispanic male got a black shirt blue
jeans standing in the front yard he's
got two machetes in his hand put it down
man go today civilian shoot and upload
police encounters to the internet every
day using tiny cameras on their cell
phones and other mobile devices in fact
it may be easier than ever to keep the
police accountable with technology but
now police are looking to keep civilians
accountable as well using tiny cameras
of their own we sat down with former
seattle police officer steve ward who
left the force to start v vu a company
that makes video cameras for police
officers what was the genesis of this
company why did you want to stop being a
police officer and go into making
cameras for police officers during my
career I had the opportunity to have
that you know aha moment and my aha
moment was I realized that dash cams
only captured about 5% of what a cop
does and I wanted to capture a hundred
percent of what a cop does after writing
an article for mountain-bike magazine
about Seattle police officers that
patrol mountain terrain by bike the
publication sent out a photographer to
take a few photos of Ward one of the
things the photographer did is he put a
camera around my neck and he set up a
huge roll of film to take multiple
frames a second and he asked me to ride
down this hill here in Seattle so I did
and so the entire way down the hill all
I hear is that click click click of the
camera as it took all these exposures
well when I got to the bottom of the
hill I stood there and that was my aha
moment I went wait a minute I just made
a movie we need to put the camera on the
cop these dash cam sir big there in the
car I don't even have a car I'm on a
bike so I thought somebody needs to do
this that was in the mid 90s and it took
me all the way till 2007 until the
technology existed where I could
actually make a small wearable camera
for cops on our cameras you just flip
the switch down in your recording and
when you're done recording you flip the
switch up and notice we could have a big
switch you could do it under stress with
gloves on in inclement weather there's a
green circle that surrounds the that's
around the lens of the camera talk about
that this piece is what we call it the
visible indicator that recording is
occurring we want everybody to know our
cameras are being
we're not a surreptitious camera company
we don't make spy cams we make very
overt video cameras and we want people
to know they're being recorded everybody
behaves better when they're on video
both parties can I handle it as other
guys it's really light it's like a I
imagine it it's designed like that so
you could run down the streets after a
suspects or something right it's gotta
be unobtrusive for the police officer
the bigger it is the more ways the more
could potentially get in their way and
actually create a dangerous situation
for the police officer so it's gonna be
small and it's got to be lightweight and
easy to use am i recording myself right
now you are you've seen cops every
there's a reason cops is still on the
air today people really have a desire to
know what their community police are
doing and so they watch cops just find
out what police works all about well now
that we have body cams or dash cams in
police departments it allows community
members to actually go in not
necessarily to be protected but just to
see what they're doing get a flavor for
what their city town look locations like
what kind of crime occurs how their
police officers are acting and sometimes
the footage that comes back can be
chilling get on the ground stop and get
on congr and now this is a video of a
police encounter provided to us by V vu
it shows how valuable video can be after
the fact but there is still a question
of who controls the data recorded what's
to stop an officer from editing or
manipulating the video our software
platform prevents officers from altering
deleting copying editing uploading to
YouTube any of the videos that the cops
take what it does is just just another
step to prove that the cops aren't doing
anything nefarious this is something
that is a job of passion for you you
were a law enforcement officer for 15
years you decided one day you wanted to
just go into technology and policing
what was the impetus for it beyond just
he thought it was cool it's a
culmination of 15 years of police work
and in my 15 years as most cops do I had
some complaints there's no way that you
against you against me okay oh
absolutely it's there's no way that you
can put somebody in up
of such great responsibilities
interacting with the public and not get
a complaint here and there the more
proactive or the more work that a police
officer does the more likely that
they're going to get a complain take
Seattle for instance in the early 90s
our police department put out a program
to actually help people file complaints
if they thought that something was going
on on and that was for the sake of
transparency well out of all the
complaints that I got in my career none
of them were ever sustained found it to
be true they're all false typically you
know a lot of people file complaints
against an officer to raise a question
at trial so that if there's a question
or an investigation against the officer
at trial they have a more likely chance
at convincing one of the jurors that the
officer might be hiding something last
year the New York Times reported that
the city of Rialto California was able
to cut down a complaints against
officers by 88 percent over the previous
year when it gave its officers body
cameras even use of force by officers
fell by almost 60% number so strong that
more officers might have videos that end
like this one
you